it's time for another scare to do so
flora do Manon yes yes yes another one
how many more how many more is he gonna
make oh geez I sure hope no one calls me
out on it for milking a series cuz that
has never been done before looking at
you mr. happy wills now let's have a
little better okay is that too much -
last week I asked you to send in some
videos I'm not gonna do that because
there were goddamn awful so the first
stop is a cranberry capital of the world
wardens Wisconsin it was amazing seeing
these vast fields of cranberries this
close so I decided it's really good look
really some on my own he's gonna fall in
ha ha ha ha ha I didn't see that one
coming oh my god that's hilarious a look
get some of my own oh my god these are
funny there's a story behind my skin
it's a mosaic of all the faces before it
I'm English Irish German and Cherokee
I'm a hundred percent I never pressed
the pause button so fast in my life
oh my god thumps I'm sweating
no that was close one Christian channel
Christian channel this the third circle
tonight we talked about this the first
two
[Applause]
what a gangster you can't tell Jesse to
do nothing
he is so grounded you're so grounded
what do you let him drive then what the
heck of it ah I seen this so good his
face
it's just like you got me you got me mag
bootiful who are safer drivers men or
women well according to a new survey 55
percent of adults feel that women are
most responsible for minor fender
benders while 78 percent blame men for
most fatal crashes please note that the
percentage in these pie graphs do not
add up to 100% because the math was done
by a woman but oh those are you hissing
at that jerk it should be noted that
that joke was written by a woman so now
you don't know what the hell they do
[Applause]
no I'm just kidding we don't hire women
[Music]
moving on moving on thank you thank you
so much for masturbating over my stream
and donating two thousand dollars you
virgin on the board okay everybody just
comes in here saying I do this for the
money no I don't I do it cuz I love it
wow that wasn't no Felix Christian
Channel and stop lifting all right what
do we got what do we got why don't we
get oh maybe I need a friend for sleepy
maybe that's his problem
okay it's like me what do you think of
it was a good idea to you know we did to
touch it oh [ __ ] kill you oh [ __ ]
where is that from wait it's a song hell
yeah I made me ha ha ha but I still
haven't lost ok why don't we get that
damn it's so hard to be a Christian
Channel these days people don't
understand people don't understand you
can't kill a bull with an apple idiots
these morons
ok ok a more practice framing carpenter
can sing it now with three hits wait
sorry what the heck is memes from
Estonia what is that what and an
experienced carpenter can sink one with
two hits but only an alpha knows how to
drive an L with a single hit uh-huh okay
yeah how you gonna do that Oh God
family-friendly memes from Estonia I
approve of you thank you very much
Estonia for your kid for keeping it
family friendly Thank You Estonia you
know usually when you go to the eastern
sides and people start looking like this
it's it's and then it's never good it's
real explosions drugs guns okay as
family freedom from Estonia very nice
very nice family friendly mean from
Estonia I really appreciate it thank you
okay I see where this is going and I'm
going to choose to stop there
but thank you it could be family
friendly holy moly what's the context
here please someone fill me in fill me
in what is happening here where is he
holy moly thank you for not swearing
thank you for keeping it real
holy moly is is a is a family-friendly
statement holy moly indeed as you guys
can see Luke he kill me with the stun
stun he can't use a stun yeah guys look
what yeah yeah look guys look look hey
disconnected yeah guys thanks for
watching guys this guy it's the next day
I'm PewDiePie my god what a talent oh my
god
very nice berry no is that a chicken
let's get it is those the quick ones
that get me man I don't even know what
is this oh shiz oh hey can't censor that
oh my yeah go in for the attack dude
look at that sneaky he's floating over
look he misses the broom a cruise you'll
miss you can't miss from that distance
the [ __ ] is gonna get you the brewery is
dead at this point and then I assume
what happens here is that he dies as
well from the [ __ ] I don't know where I
[Applause]
don't know what the same me Oh Nikolas
this train is gonna crash into these
five people should we move the Train to
go this way or should we let it go that
way which way should
wow that's really interesting teaching a
child moral dilemmas at Eden and an
early age
this child it's a brilliant mind it's a
genius my god of course
literally the answer no one is ever
given to this dilemma that is right
little Timmy if we move over the lady
she can get killed as well
is a genius clearly he's just respecting
women here and there's nothing else to
it well what do you know
did you laugh or did you lose why do I
always say that you know what Hecate I'm
going with it if you enjoyed the video
remember to buy my chair everyone I sell
shares sheriff sheriff chairs see you
next week with another one and remember
kids stay family friendly Christian who
am i anymore I don't promised for the
good old times sake let's get my money
let's give them what they wanted let's
give them what they want they want a
broke this thing no I know you want to
brofist there it is classic 2012 come on
in honey nothing bad is gonna happen
I promise you know what give it a little
kiss give it okay you kiss it too you
kiss it too
lick it lick it